could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
making moves yeah on a dance floor
this means so so much to me everything i
touched was turned into gold everyone
wanted a piece of me and how does an 18
19 year old deal with that
the height of success when it is like
whoa there's so much of the
human part that's being unmet i felt
like i was starting to make music the
tick boxes when i started to abandon
myself and i started to do things that
just weren't in alignment it was a point
where i had dark thoughts i was just
like i can't live my life like this what
people enjoyed for me was music and i
realized that from when i came back to
london i feel like the kid again and
trust me
the crowd are gonna go off when they
hear something soon okay
so 22 years later if you could whisper
in the ear of your 14 year old self what
would you whisper
listen cray
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
craig
i've got some lyrics that i wanted to
recite to you okay
it's another day at school
and he's just walking out the door
got his rucksack on his back and his
feet dragging on the floor always late
but when he's questioned he can't think
of what to say hides the bruises from
the teachers hoping that they'd go away
even though his mum and dad they both
got problems of their own caught in a
catch-22 but he'd still rather be at
home cries himself to sleep and praise
when he wakes up things might have
changed but everything's the same
that's from your record johnny from
2006. yeah
that was a uh
that was a song that had to
it was the first time i think kind of
opening up and
and expressing
uh
experience that
i felt that i had maybe on a lesser
degree to a lot of other people in my
school i think at school like in my my
secondary school i had a very i had a
beautiful upbringing i enjoyed life was
a playful kid i loved music
but secondary school all boys school
went to belmore and southampton and for
the majority of it was it was great
times but
when you come in in your early years and
you've got the older the older boys in
there and they're like yo
you got two pound and you know i haven't
got two pounds and push you up again you
got two pound on you like and then it's
not a case of like if you got the money
he's like let me check in your pockets
let me try and pull out the pockets a
minute
so
as a lesser degree of the bullying i was
like i was experiencing it
physically in the corridors so i kind of
so when i was starting to write that
song i was drawing from i had to go to
how did it feel when that was happening
and it only happened with one one one
guy in one period in the school
so i understood what bullying was i mean
that was i was i was felt helpless i
couldn't he was two years older
stronger
could rough me up if we really wanted to
but then also i was seeing other people
who were getting a real i was getting a
psychological element but there was a
deeper side of that psychology of when
they say tell the teacher they'll deal
with it
this is the thing with bullying is that
i agree
that it needs to be spoken to someone
you can confide in
but sometimes that kind of very rushing
you've told the teacher they rush in
they it's all out in the open
i was seeing kids who would then have
the kid waiting outside of school for
them or it might be that they they're
being bullied by someone from a
different school even
so they'd be coming out to the school
gates thinking okay well i'm on my way
home no it's about to start when you get
on the bus to go home
so the whole world is now outside of
school you've finished at 3 p.m and now
it's it's beginning for you so it was i
felt deeply that i needed to write on
that um
and like i said my mom and dad had their
own things going on um in their lives
and
and i spoke to my mom i wrote the song
while i was in southampton i've got like
a studio when i was down there and i
played it to her because i wanted her to
also know that
mum you've always been supportive to me
like if i needed to speak to you if i
needed to say things but
with bullying there is an element where
you want to say something to the closest
person in your life be it your family so
your mother or your father
um and i wanted to really portray that
in the song properly but i wanted to
have that comment with my mum to let her
know i knew that you would have always
if i needed to speak to you would have
been there because i do say your
problems of your own and i've tried to
tell you so many times you're not
listening and that is the case and a lot
of the cases of bullying that even
family aren't listening so who do you
turn to
so um
music has been that that song in
particular i think i was a journey my
grandma had passed away at the same time
um
it was a
i just needed to get things off my chest
that i felt like this is past a romantic
love song i need to
help people
in in a way that wasn't trying to preach
it was just let me tell stories
anecdotes and i do it through music so
and you were bullied for your weight
back then as well right
yeah the well the weight one was
it's funny because like
you like to tell the story differently
when you're in a slightly different
place and position you you'll tell it
like nah well you know i was
and i like i like everything about this
is what
your podcast for me has always and i
wanted to tell you off the bat
what i love about you is that you're
bringing out so much so much depth in
people and you already know how much
love i got for you anyway
appreciate it the being overweight thing
now i see it as actually in hindsight it
actually
it brought out so many
things wonderful things that had to kind
of that have been repressed for a long
period of time but at the time
the social standard was you need to look
a certain way um
the the captain of school football team
tended to be the one that the girls were
interested in you were the you were the
slightly overweight one that they cry on
your shoulder tell you all your problems
have this real you have a real empathic
uh relationship you'd be like what this
is connection this is real relationship
but we didn't want to take any further
than that
well
he's the one look at the way he scored
the goal so then you've already got this
early
um imprint of what society expects of
you and you start trying to conform to
that so there are periods where i'd look
in
walking down the high street and i look
in the in the in the glass the
reflection in the glass
and i just looking like
you're just feeling sorry for yourself
feeling like the jeans ain't fitting
quite right and the
jacket's not and you're getting
bigger sizes and then you're just
feeling like i'm doing all the fit i'm
doing i could run i had some i had some
legs on me you know and probably boys
that's going to be like bro you weren't
if you weren't right faster runner which
part do you run it but i'll tell the
story i'm on the mic
um
so i can move but i was just carrying a
lot of weight
um but not unhealthy i think there was a
point that when it became unhealthy is
when i realized that my weight had i was
like 15 and i think my weight had was
starting to get to i was 14 and my
weight got to 14 and a half stone so i
was starting to get
over my age in weight you know and i was
like maybe i need to slightly reign this
in a little bit health wise
but i ask these questions because and i
always start with childhood on this
podcast and i i've i've reflected on
this over and over again and thought
maybe i should start somewhere else but
i know from my own experiences that my
own like childhood traumas or the things
that made me feel a bit invalid or
insecure or felt feel shame when i was
younger
ended up being like the biggest drivers
in my life so when i sit here i'm trying
to find out why you know you got really
into fitness
and why you became you know who you
became i always start with like what
were the things when you were a kid that
made you feel shame invalid like you
didn't fit in and and those tend to be
the pathway to people's you know
people's greatness in a weird way 100
like it all
you're you're you've got this this
period where your heart's open you want
to you're experiencing life you're a
child like you said you're a child
you're a puppy you just you don't know
and then all of a sudden you get that oh
is that oh that oh i can't do that oh
that's the way to go and you're you're
you're getting all that you're
imprinting all these patterns that
only later you start to realize in in
your not even saying teenage years i
think it's still in adolescent years at
that point but when maybe in your 20s
start to unpack things just if you if
you're conscious you're starting to
recognize that this doesn't seem to line
up with my truth and then into the 30s
for me it was like well i have to unpack
all this stuff that was like the
overweight thing
because you're exactly right that it
started then
and listen i could i could eat sweets
like cadbury's boost bars were getting
eaten like crazy i'd go to the the
news agents before i went to school to
get on the bus
i'd be also selling chocolate as well so
i had like a little yeah yeah i was
early days entrepreneur early days yeah
you'd find the the chocolate that was
like had about two weeks left before it
was out date and you'd i'd work that in
my in my lessons like listen i knew i
had like from nine till
11 before there was a there was a tuck
shot break so i could just set the tone
as to how much i want to sell it for
well you want a mars bar for yeah it's a
pound fifty but we're gonna pound fifty
okay brother wait till 11 then you can
go you can get it for 35 p whatever it
is
good pound in the okay cool pound
that was the leverage was incredible
right
so i always had an affiliation and one
of my favorite movies is willy wonka
chocolate factory so i think that set
the tone anyway i've got a bit of
augustus group in me i've got i think
we've got all the myriad of characters
in that movie is me and ultimately
charlie like you know i mean um
so yeah so it's just i've been unpacking
it a lot of those things and realizing
that my my health streak
that i've got went on at sort of in when
i was in some miami sort of time and
even slightly before that
was all to do with this childhood thing
of i've got to the six-pack the captain
the school football team it's funny how
like those things like you're like whoa
and it wasn't even and the crazy thing
with it is that
when i got into the music when i started
rewinding blowing up it was people just
want to hear me sing yeah it was like
they didn't care if my stomach was here
there six pack one pack two pack and by
the way everyone everyone has a six-pack
underneath so just know that otherwise
your stomach's gonna fall out so if
that's the saving grace for everyone
don't worry about the fat content and
the fat percent there's a six-pack
underneath everyone so walk out on the
street and feel confident with that
that's great it's not telling people
that um you talked in those lyrics but
then also then you talked about your
parents and you said there was i know
again that's another dynamic because
those are the for most people the most
formative figures in their life of
course what was the relationship with
your parents and you said they had
things going on that that were kind of
it sounded like distracting
them
from the things that were going on in
your school life yeah i mean
my mum and dad broke up uh got divorced
when i was eight
um
but the beautiful thing is that my my
dad always would come pick me up on the
weekends on on a sunday and it would
either be going to like holton's park
like um
go-karting or i'd be helping him fix a
kitchen um which i've got i would say to
my dad like dad like what i'm going to
fix the kitchen like like can we and i
just remember that the tools and the dry
dust i think
but i love those times with my dad yeah
he really made an effort and our drives
in his car playing reggae music heavily
influenced everything that i was going
through
and for my mom it was like
she was working nine to five
so my grandma and my mother would pretty
much raising me my grandma would come
pick me up from school when my mum was
at work so
i had a lot of feminine energy in my
life which
i'm really grateful for because it set
the tone for how i
wrote a lot of my songs even seven days
i mean i'm saying making love
17 years old writing a song who's saying
making love
on wednesday i mean you listen to the
songs now if they're not they're using
that kind of language but it was that i
got there's a respect i had for my from
my mother from my grandmother
and the fact even for my dad i didn't
want him i'm cussing out on record like
that would just be like yeah we need to
like speak about this so i just was i
thought i got a really good upbringing
but at the same time i didn't have a
great model of
family life at home i got a lot of
feminine energy and female
love and tension and care and all the
things that you love from your mummy and
grandma and then my dad was just like
always had my back and i've got you but
i've never never seen them together
so
i think again looking at
childhood
imprints and patterns as how they affect
you later on
relationship with with women was
something i've always been really close
to but i also had never had a model of
how do you how do you stay together with
like the relationship part like i'm a
romantic but if you look at your
relationships like they haven't really
worked out too well or you've been
guarded
and it's a journey of again of
is this story true
there's a point where you've got to be
conscious enough to actually ask that
question and it tends to knock on the
door and the intuition's always there
sort of saying we can have this convo if
you want like we can i'll present you
with the books i can present you with
the click on the right podcast to go to
i'll get you to we can unpack this
someone will inspire you to do that
exactly but there's also
what i've seen now and i feel i feel
very i feel
open enough to be apologetic for
relationships that
i i didn't my heart was closed
off on the basis that not only from the
family modeling but also
your first break heartbreak so for me it
was like i
was so open um and i had that first
heartbreak and it just went from a kid
who was had his heart open and thought
this is it and you're into me and it's
gonna and then all of a sudden it just
crashed and i was like well
that feeling and i'd never
felt anything like that before where i
was like i i didn't know who to turn to
it was like i felt that after after
early childhood
sweetheart breakup
my heart had kind of closed down and i i
feel sorry for
the the the girls and and women in the
last days of my life tried to open my
heart up and that's all they were trying
to do there's there was things that went
a bit toxic and went but i have to own
those situations a lot of guys was like
yeah well she's the the girl was like
this or she was crazy no no forget all
of that
i walked into that and i stepped in with
a certain kind of energy and i gave off
a certain feeling and
especially if you're having sexual
relationships there's a
there's an energy exchange between two
people and you can play off it's like no
but we had an unwritten agreement where
it was like no strings attached and you
can play that game as much as you want
get enough karma
you'll start to see that there'll be
some someone who'll be your teacher at
some point and i thank
everyone in my life that i've had
relations with i thank you for teaching
me in some way i want to go on record
with that because i feel like it's
something that i've always
i now get it that i was moving a little
bit reckless in the early times with the
music and everything going on
and there were there were people trying
to
get to my heart and i was just like nope
got this thing it's easier to keep it
arm's length and it just doesn't work
like that so two questions on that then
what was the evidence or the story that
your
parents your parents relationship taught
you or left you with okay for better for
worse and then that first heartbreak
what were the two stories those two
incidents
told you about relationships so
having no
modeling of what real relationship is it
it showed me early from from mum and dad
as much as i love them with all of my
heart that
being single
is the best way to get through life just
stay single because i never saw my
mother with another partner i never
really saw my dad with another partner
um and i have sisters and brothers but i
never i
i never and of of my dad's other
relationships they had
um and i love them equally but it's just
i never had any
clear
reason to say that relationship works
and then it reinforces so the story adds
on later on in your life you start to
see how people
are with each other who are in
relationships and you get friends who
are in relationships and they may be
cheating on their partner or you're
seeing how
there's been some scenarios where a girl
says she's she's in a relationship
and
thankfully it hasn't been husband
already but there's been relationships
i'm not going to be there the guys say i
i've never met anyone who's in something
and i'll tell you a story that i was
breaking up we're not really in it but
you're you're starting it's reinforcing
the same thing of
well stay single then yeah don't get
involved in all this because you your
heart will be protected and life is good
and we can keep our arms laying then
link that into the the first breakup
first heartbreak heart was open
gave everything relationship i'm all in
like i'm gonna as a child i was like
okay
it's hard psychologically you don't
really understand what's going on in
your in your family your parents but you
just at school now i'm you see a girl
falling a falling for you and
she's into you and it's all happening
and it could have been i think it was
only like about a week week and a half
yeah the break really it wasn't it was
this we're talking early early days but
when your heart is fully open yeah
the crushing feeling i had after that
set the tone
for
the rest of my life until now i've
unpacked the whole thing which which
goes hand in hand with some of the songs
i've written on albums before where i'm
talking about breakups the song called
thief in the night which is about a girl
who like
why did you have to end up being with my
best friend like why did there's moments
where i'm looking back thinking when i
was writing that song what was i feeling
i was being the same heartbreak that i
had at the same
zero understanding of what relationship
is and then now i see
it's all about relationship
it's all about opening your heart up
again the same feeling that i think we
both share when you said that you had
your moments of the trigger points in
your life you had to open up again and
you met someone who met you a place to
help you through that which is even
better when you meet someone's conscious
and gets it says yeah i've got you i
know baby steps if we need to but i'm
with you yeah
i'm at that place now where i'm like
do you think my heart's open
eyes open man it's open in a way that
i'm
i'm down if it if something tried to try
to close it down
i'm open as much as i was when i first
had my heart open and i wouldn't have
said that maybe in a few years back the
journey has kind of rapidly kind of
entered into a phase where i just know
that that's the the truth of the matter
and where are you relationship wise
single at the moment
which
is
again you have
especially as as as a guy and i can
really kind of speak on my experiences
and and
we tend to
our actions have to line up with the way
that we
we're feeling and and i felt that there
was times when i was talking a good talk
but the way i'm the way i'm acting is no
different than what i was acting before
so then as a part we have to pull back
the faders and be like okay well
this means that i can't enter into
things where it's
purely well this had changed long term
ten years ago for me that
the objectifying of women that that
thing it was something where i had to
just check myself and be like what is
this
patterning that you have of a look and
how someone's got to be in and that's
all part of the same thing that was
happening as a kid
that it was it was very dreamy but
without the
relationship and now it's flipped i i
look for a relationship in in i want to
have a situation where i can connect
with you now regardless of look if we're
not going to a place where we can go
there we can laugh life is one of the
biggest values of of any relationship
someone makes me laugh cry
uncontrollably you've always got half of
my heart already yeah because that's
going to save you when the relationship
has its ups and downs so the down is
when you need someone who can bring that
because trust me the romantic phase
as as we all know that's intoxicating
yeah when you wake up after the hangover
and it's real you're still having the
same feeling and love starts then that
hangover
right then that's when you're gonna ask
yourself am i really in love the
romantic thing that's this bit of
sweetness
have you had a long-term relationship
it would sound so short for so many
people for me it felt long two and a
half years was probably my longest
relationship and the same as me and even
then like i don't feel like i opened my
heart i really felt that the girl was
really trying to get me to to break down
some walls and
i i go on record that as as toxic as
things can go with a little bit of time
and separation you look at it book it
back and you say thank you because you
taught me so much about how i was moving
and how i was going on and i'm a better
man for that because now i can open my
heart like this because a lot of guys
don't want to talk like they want to
keep it cool
one of the other things talking about
things that kind of invalidated us when
we were younger or that we were aspiring
to i saw this quote i actually saw a
picture of the estate you lived on and
it's um i'm gonna say
it's not the estate that i would wish to
have lived on
i don't want to criticize you know an
area but it's not it didn't look i saw
like a grey apartment apartment block
and it looked like a
quite you know
it was a council estate yeah um and you
the quote you said was you were a kid
looking out of your bedroom window at
the estate car park imagining jacuzzis
do you know what i think to correct the
quote even more easier yeah because the
jacuzzi one like
it's funny cause i was talking about
this only yesterday about like when i
was speaking about film me in and i was
like yeah i was like jumped in the
jacuzzi i was thinking
well which accuser was actually jumping
in because last time i checked you were
in a two bedroom flat with your mum yet
so the only accused you were jumping was
your bath yeah so that's that's put that
record and you're in a four by four yeah
okay cool so which driving license did
you have at that point because you were
only like 15 16 when you were right
there was aspirations aspirations like
looking out of that window overlooking
that car park
what my grandmother brought to
to the table in terms of like i mean the
love that my mom just with my family i'm
just very grateful for that upbringing
but my grandma as grandmas do
you know make sure you you get the right
food in you make sure you wear the
jacket you know i mean it's going to get
cold it's going to rain later on and
you're like grandma then it rains they
just have this wisdom yeah
but
she had a beautiful little garden
in the house that she lived and it was
like five minutes away from where i
lived and i was just like that for me
wasn't was enough as an inspiration
to say if i could have a house with a
garden in southampton
we're good here i mean
little did i know that
how it would cascade from the music into
yeah just that that times 10 in terms of
just like my eyes being open but it was
that inspiration for my grandma and i
looked at the car park and it was like
okay it kept me on my camera my grind
like council estate
working class family
growing up
made me have to make ends meet where
secondary school wasn't really setting
me up for when i leave here i was like i
was already doing my market stall
selling of uh chocolates at school
already had that going and i was already
doing mixtapes so that was my kind of
go-to in the barbers selling mixtapes
for
10 pounds that i'd be doing at home
which would buy another piece of
equipment that i'd get another speak
another pair of speakers or another
mini disc player to record on then i was
getting a printer so i could print my
own covers then i i was
everything i kind of am doing now
weirdly enough
is no different than what i was doing
when i was a kid i literally had my
whole little factory of making tunes
trying to have a little business going
on
so i could make ends meet in my own way
without having to try and pull money
from my mum because she already had her
own things going on and she supported me
beyond like i think she was going deeply
into overdrafts just to make my my life
feel comfortable you've got the sega
mega drive right with the sonic the
hedgehog and there's those games there
yes i brought my memories
yeah you got that but
when i think back there was
wherever my money was get where my mom
was getting this money from like she was
deeply in debt so when you look back you
say mom the love i have for you like
nine to five and making me feel like i
was getting everything there anyway
other kids getting you know what i mean
but
and my dad you know i mean like he
support he would he would never no one
could cross me no one no one could do
anything bad to my dad had me they'd
have to cross my dad and that was the
kind of and that protection is good to a
certain degree but then when you grow up
that's not there to do the things so how
where's that part
so you're going to understand
i've got so much feminine energy in me
and that part but i need the
speaking of truth
action now
so is the
the yang my man the yang yeah
so you talk about music there and one of
the things that was really remarkable
reading through your story is how early
music came into your world and how early
you started
like selling mixtapes and
i sat here with i sat here with many
musicians and it tends tended to happen
a little bit later in life even diplo
sat here last week and the diplo it was
i don't know he was 25 or something
before he really started going in music
but you were you were young i know your
dad had an influence on that because he
was very into reggae yeah and he was in
a reggae band right yes but where did
music show up in your life and then and
how did that obsession kind of like take
hold
um
i mean it was early
like i said when i earlier on when i
said like you know high five when you
come into the world i feel that and you
you lose of the cognitive understanding
as to what's going on and why we're here
and but there's something intuitively
that's pulling you in certain directions
and as a child you very much honor that
you just go in the direction so i was
always intrigued by the little hi-fi set
up my mom had it in the flat with a big
box of records
and i'd just be flicking through them
and i and there was a vinyl in there
there was ebony rockers which is my
dad's reggae group which more recently
there's a mural now in southampton
they've put on on on ogall road
huge moral that says about ebony rockers
and i'm thinking wow i'm so proud of my
dad i was like yes dad because you are a
musician in your heart bass guitar
player the the group were talking about
um social issues that were going on
in the 70s 80s
and
being able to put that on record and
talk about injustices that were going on
in their lives at southampton and have
it on record but now you're getting
recognized for that oh man like i just
love love my dad for that it's like i'm
just so happy for him so i was looking
at records and i pulled out his record
and i'd be like every new rockers and my
mum would say yeah that's your dad's
group and i'd be like well my dad's like
i really don't i'm talking like five six
years old looking like well my dad's in
a group
so i know there's definitely there's
some lineage there there's dna that's
coming through musically my mum was
always into stevie wonder and michael
jackson
uh my first ever seven inch i ever
bought was uh
it was human nature oh really michael
jackson yeah because it was on a seven
inch
it was in a there was a small little box
next to the 12-inch
um it's the first one i bought that's
one let me tell it to the right it's the
first one i bought first song i ever
bought so that's why and i mean look at
the lyric of the song yeah it couldn't
be any more perfect as a song of like
being conscious and understanding the
world
so yeah so i had a
and then there was there was the bit of
donny osmond in there because my mom was
a big fan of the osmonds which was a big
group back of the day
um
mixed with the stevies and the michaels
and and and then also having my dad's
reggae deep reggie from bearish hammond
to sanchez
uh
terra fabulous budget bantam beanie man
bounty like early like i'm a sound man
at heart i think when i'm in the studio
people are like you literally are with
your banter but no one's actually see
like hearing you do this yeah because i
go into this
reggae kilimanjaro david rodigan
uh black cat sound system in me so when
i see carnival i'm just like
it's me sitting up and post it up with a
little bit of rice and chicken
a little budweiser by a speaker and i'm
good
so yeah man that music
started off early and then i just i just
felt like it just was gravitating
towards it when was the first time you
made music in any kind of computer um
the first time i made music was
my dad got me a hi-fi system called
studio 100. for anyone who knows that it
was like a big box like huge like box
with loads of faders on the front he
came home one day like he came to the
house said craig i got you the studio
100 like whoa what am i supposed to do
with this i have no idea
so i had loads of fades loads of
microphones with different colored um
foam capsules on the top
looked the business with a with a record
deck on top
two twin cassette decks
and lots of switches that i didn't
understand what's going on but i was
excited because i was like wow this is
the first time i might be able to record
something so i was just fully investing
and when you're a kid you learn all the
things you know all the
so i started to record
i would have said i was
11 11 12 years old when that came
through
and i you put a tdk cassette tape
there was a d90 was like the basic uh
one or you if you're feeling kind of
saucy with it you have like a chrome or
a or a metal there's a two pound forty
nine in those ones but if you went from
normal d9 it was like a little 69b one
i put i buy two of them you record into
one tape
so i put the first lead line of
something and a lot of my early songs
were just sounding like i was literally
just lifting the vocals from every other
song that i was listening to and then
i didn't quite get the memo of oh we
have to change the melody that much for
it to not be sound like i'm singing
jodeci freaking you or boys to men why
does it sound like you literally just
changed like the the road to street on
end of the road
you have to do a bit more than that
which i kind of you'll learn quickly if
you don't get the memo yeah um but yes i
start to bounce the vocals down so you
sing onto one cassette you put that in
the bottom
tape cassette you then put a fresh one
in the top and you let that play and you
record on top so you were dubbing on top
of your vocal the quality was
diminishing every time you did that yeah
because this is an old school start but
i was starting to finish
a song i was feeling very
very proud of myself that i could
actually write a song how old
i would have been like yeah like them 12
years old 11 12 years old
but yeah that kind of led into
a world very nourished with r b reggae
but also the
the pop soul element tension derby was
the first
show i ever went to at the guildhall in
southampton it blew my mind i saw this
guy's front row i just saw him like
he was moving like
prince with marvin gabe he had the voice
like a stevie wonder with michael
jackson the hard line according to album
was like it was like seven eight million
albums there's a huge record for him
with the the breakout song sign your
name across my heart again look at the
the the messages sign your name across
my heart yeah
i'm like finally we're getting the
message now i need to let someone sign
it fully you know i mean and
capitals hold that
but changed my life i was like if i can
i'd love to do what that guy does
from 11 12 where you're messing around
with those cassettes
to
i think when i've heard you kind of kind
of recount it your first break was
winning that songwriting contest with
damage wasn't it yes was that would you
consider that to be your first kind of
like break
opportunity you know what it's like
it gave me it gave me the first taste of
of um reinforcing that i could actually
do this like i thought it was a bright
break like i was gonna we've done it
here yeah i've written the song i'm
ready it's on the back of it's on the b
side of wonderful tonight there at
clapton cover which was the lead single
i'm telling everyone it went to number
two in the charts i'm telling all my
friends it's because of obviously by
song i'm ready
not the classic wonderful tonight that
they've covered right
um
but i thought it was off the back and i
actually sang vocals on that did bvs on
the song they let me come up to london
met the guys i was just like wow this is
like a dream come true
but i didn't
off the back of it was like okay i was
in the shops for a few weeks
but nothing it went quiet after that how
old were you when you won that
songwriting competition for the boy band
damage how i would have said i was 14 uh
so you're 2015. you start messing around
with music at about 11ish you said right
and then at 14 you win the songwriting
competition for the boy band damage
um and that's what like three years of
just continuing to mess around and
develop and practice and just play
around with music right between that
time yeah yeah it was it was um
and again the support of my mum and dad
in in ways that now i'm just like so
thankful for of by bringing that studio
100 piece of equipment that for me to
record
you know my first record deck all those
things now i was the kid looking through
the music store like i wish i could have
that we showed you that one if i could
get that one equalizer it would i could
mix it i was just that i'm nerdy with it
and they would always somehow have a 10
pound and a 20 pound ready for me to
help me out and i had my
my chocolate thing going also
something really interesting about you
saying nerdy with it because
the guests that i sat here with
specifically the musicians
it always seems to be the case that when
they were younger or just before you
know maybe in the 10 years before they
blew up or whatever they were just like
really nerdy with music there wasn't
really an intention of being the
greatest or getting the number one
albums they were just like obsessed even
wretch 32 when he sat here is the same
thing he was just clearly just nerdy
with it very very young age and i think
that's that's really important to point
out because the pathway to getting to
where you got to in your life right
isn't that doesn't appear to be
um or at least the starting point
doesn't appear to be this obsession with
becoming a superstar it's this kind of
nerdy fascination because you spent
three years between 11 and 14 just
messing around with cassettes on some
piece of hardware that your dad bought
yeah yeah of course it's it it did feel
that
my obsession with music
like when i when i look back and it's
different now because i have this i have
the same kid in me that wants to do the
same thing that i may have done in those
periods of time especially when i start
collecting vinyl like i knew every
producer i knew where the snare was on
this track was taken from a changing
faces song over there and this record
over here uses the kick drum from there
the bass is using
i was in it like i had everything in
alphabetical order with the plastic um
sleeves that they all went in room was
getting to the point where i couldn't
fit in my room for records so i was
really living it to the point where i'd
swap shop with records i'd be like like
the other djs would say
if i got to london get records bring
them back those days djs were the
go-to like he wasn't like you go on
new music friday and you get a thousand
songs to kind of to look through
it was like if the dj played in the club
you better go speak to the dj find out
where he got it from because he he's got
there's 10 copies maybe and there's a
promo that's not going to come out for
six months literally songs were like you
had time because it was physical
where are you going to go you can't copy
this unless you've got a lathe and
you're going to start to print acetates
in your house so you have to wait so i
when you went out to london especially
because this was like the hub for where
everything was being made and printed up
i come back sometimes from that to
slammed him with some record dj's almost
where you get that quick where are you
i said yeah you know i gotta swap you a
faith evans
i just can't and a jade for the tune
that you got and i said
maybe give me a little 10 pound extra
for that you could you could it was all
wise but i just it was such a fun time
because things were slower
and i love it now but it's just there's
a lot to get into there's a lot of music
being released just to to keep up with
the flex of it
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein
if you haven't tried the cure protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like the salted caramel is my
favorite i've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is
the one
between 14 and 18 then
what happens then for you i'd gone from
the songwriting competition
uh a moment where it was like okay this
is the the this is the thing but then it
can carry on where okay this wasn't
necessarily the big breakthrough
heavily into the into collecting records
i started to dj early on i was mc at
first for
uh another dj called dj flash who i
respect so much because he brought a lot
into my life to to be
able to be a chaperone for me really he
knew my dad um and
he was 10 years older than me and i at
14 i looked a little older as well so i
couldn't kind of get i could style it to
get into clubs with him and he'd let me
be his mc so i'd be called mcfade and i
was just like you know i mean their fade
was chris and i just thought that was
the
honor that's crazy and then he give me
like a he gave me a little slot uh to
play maybe a little 15 minutes at the
end of his dj set so in southampton he
was playing most of the kind of big
clubs there and he introduced me to the
cajun zoo in bournemouth um we do a
couple shows in in portsmouth so i was
like his i was his mc and also his box
boy as well because trust me the back
was getting like
smashed picking up those heavy boxes
yeah it's different when you're wearing
the chain with the mp3 on it it's
different when you're picking up those
boxes right your your squat game's got
to be really on the point your glutes
will be you'll be fired up
but i'd always do this thing with him
and i'd be like
a flashback
i was trying to find like a girl he had
his eyes on and he'd be watching all
through the night i'd be like i think
she she keeps looking at you man you
need to go you need to go and speak to
her he goes yeah but i just don't worry
i've got you i'll let me you go speak to
her because she's gonna go and it's all
gonna okay cool
handle the four i under the fort don't
you worry so i play like a little half
an hour i think yeah he's skirting
around should i go and speak to her and
he's just standing next to her he goes
over for the for the move she blows him
out completely because you're never
looking at him at all for the whole
thing right i've got a 30 minute dj
setting then he's come back like great
it's like she didn't even i guess i know
she was looking at you all the time i'm
not sure
you've got to find your ways yeah but i
learn
from between that 14 to
to really to 16
was a period of dj and intensely then i
started to go off and do my own dj in
sets with m.c alistar who is part of the
artful dodger he does mc sets now um
and then there was kind of he was moving
i was at college i'd gone from secondary
school now i was at college a city
college i was doing an mvq level two in
electronics it was like the closest
thing i could get to music because there
wasn't like
uh production
courses that they do now which would
have been great back then it was like
how do you forge a trumpet out of metal
and
how was how do you make a guitar from
scratch with wood and i'm like you know
i just want to know how timberland makes
that or rodney jerkins makes the the
vocal sound so good could someone show
me that
and then there wasn't a course so i
thought let me do electronics because at
least that gets me closer to circuit
boards
richer sounds was around the corner
i had some wicked equipment in there i
thought even if i got a
job working there would be great i'd be
near detonate decks i'd be near twin
tape cassette decks maybe i'm getting a
discount so that was my road i was going
down djing emceeing there
never thought it would necessarily
mean meeting
mark hill and pete devrow from the
artful dodger which is where it it
really then transcended
tell me about that so
in one club it was called old orientals
um 10 minutes around the corner from
where
my i was living with my mum
was djing downstairs uh r b hip hop set
upstairs was house and garage night um
mark hill and pete devro who the
original artful dodger were playing
upstairs now these are early doors for
garage music so you're here in like
it's a london thing was playing um scott
garcia which was like a classic
garage stream from them days and
it was even like the
the
lessons in love i was coming through
robbie craig and there were just tunes
put in place and i always pop my head up
and be like it wasn't packed up there
but i was like this is this is a vibe
it's got like it's like they're layering
r b stuff now it fell over this skippy
what do you call it is it i know what
two step was it was like it's a speed
garage it was with like some eclectic
thing that's not house but it feels
uk
and then all of a sudden we got into
conversation and i was talking about all
these songs that i've been recording at
home where i didn't have a producer or
someone who could create the music for
me
i was using instrumentals and stuff to
just sing over like you'd hear a
freestyle
and then literally that
i mean this is where it's so divine like
the serendipity of it was so beautiful
mark hill
who ended up producing the whole reborn
to do it album said i've been looking
for someone who writes songs like i do
music like i've got the music things
like that but i need somebody who writes
songs you can sing and i was like oh
this is a perfect marriage and he says
i've got studios like five minutes from
here at a place called ocean village and
i was like you can't even make this up
like it was
the club like my my flat
the
old orientals place that we met the
studio was literally within a 10-minute
walk it was like all perfectly planned
and then from that the next thing i did
was record a song called uh what you're
gonna do
which was the first
release from artful dodger
and i remember it being printed up on a
on vinyl they did their own thing boxed
it all up i felt sweet when you're on a
vinyl i made it at that point
and they got up in a van and they took
it up to london they go into the record
stores and they say look we got them to
take two boxes here at this record store
and uh so in derby street and soho
records there in brixton we've got some
was like and something started to build
my man i can't
i was like just happy to be on a record
but then
all of a sudden i was getting people
saying who they've been coming back down
from london saying i'm hearing your
training played on pirate radio stations
you know i'm like what i'm hearing like
he's going off dropped the funk drop the
bass hit it and i'm like what you've
and i like but then random people saying
i i was coming back from london it's
getting played like i went to a club it
went off the dj spanned it like four
times back to back
something was bubbling
the next thing you know
i got a call from public demand who was
a label that were that got invested in
that in that record they'd done a
licensing deal for that song they said
you want to come up to london start
doing some some pas and put some
performances for this song
and so i'd love to so i called up my
mate clinton and his yellow fiesta i
remember clearly got a jamaican flag in
the back yeah just like he had it
proudly there he had like the sub
speaker in the boot going crazy the
thing was tuned up like he was coming
going to not know carnival yeah the
sound system was way more than the car
right
it sounded chris so he got up there to
slip him like
50 pounds to to get me up there get me
back and literally i go up i was getting
like two 250 300 pound for for a pa
which was good money i'm like wow this
is real money now from selling
chocolates to this kind of money
i can buy this record i can buy that and
i go to the colosseum in vauxhall um the
end
and i started twice as nice was the the
big name at the time
and i got them seeing what you're going
to do and i'd go on stage and i was this
young 15 year old kid i was 16 at the
time
walked out and they the dj even more
like any dj could play because the
artful dodger we had this sort of
agreement that if dodger were with me
performing we're doing a set together we
took half the amount for the
for the fee and if i was going off doing
a performance then i would just take the
money and if they did a dj set somewhere
they'd take it so we just had a nice
little agreement going on
so i'd go up there and the dj would you
say you're ready ready okay yeah i'm
ready ready and he'd be like
drop the phone drop the bass here that's
for the first time walking out seeing it
go off i was just like this is mad and
before i even got to sing the guys
they're spinning up and everyone's going
which is where
led to beau selecta with rewind why i
was saying that in the song it's like
bro
that was the phrase it's a cultural
reference for that music and i think
that that's where it kind of just it
just
it just was exponential after that it
just went from what you're going to do
then rewind was starting to go do its
thing
and people were just losing their minds
to that song like i remember my first
person from pa of that song
i wasn't sure if the crowd were feeling
it because it goes into this this bass
line in the chorus which is very it
feels like a half-time rmb record see so
it's like dum dude
so it's like rewind when across they
bought the letter re-eat wine you just
got the baseline doom dynamics half time
you could just be slow jam
and i saw people literally they were
standing like and it wasn't like we're
not feeding it but it's like we don't
know what to do here yeah like because
the verse has been making moves yeah on
a dance floor you got the garage things
cool and then it goes
and people like
and then when it and that was this usb
in the end
people were like you know that tune that
does that half time i don't know what a
baseline thing but it goes slowed
and it set the tone for the whole thing
that song right there
still it's like my baby because i felt
it when i walked home with my sony
walkman with my headphones on on my jack
screens just like walking back like just
listening to it thinking i don't need
there's some songs where i don't need
any feedback i don't need to tell me
what they think about it how they feel
i know in my soul
this here
is the one and it wasn't the one from
it's going to go off in a club it's just
going to go off when i go back to my
flat i had a huge sub speaker that was
probably bigger than me yeah that i had
in the corner bigger than most of my
room i had to squeeze my bed out almost
to get in
when i pressed play on that and it came
through that speaker
i was like this
i'm good i got the
the full uh
feeling that i needed so from then i was
like if this is the same for anyone else
and they feel like this then it's gone
clear and they end up being gone
and that is a
timeless timeless record i mean i
listened to it before you came in here
so i was listening to it and i was like
[ __ ] it this could have come out last
week you know what i mean it feels like
that do you see what i mean like i
played that i was like this could be
this would be a hit now
i appreciate you know what i mean though
hundreds yeah is that is that
it was a cultural record it was it feels
very timeless like i did a show the
other day yes last night and i dropped
it in
the millennials are getting crazy for it
the day ones are there going like okay
it's just like it's
it's one of those ones yeah yeah you
know what i mean yeah
so that leads you up to the to the point
where you start to release your first
solo single fill me in yeah talk to me
about that and that whole process
because that went straight to number one
um
from what you've said i know it changed
your life right from going doing these
pas and clubs to doing i think you did
wembley three nights in a row or
something yeah crazy crazy in in the
space of a couple of months as well yeah
it went like from like zero to 100 that
literally that's why it was kind of like
behind the scenes funnily enough even
though i said zero to 100 there was a
lot of learning curve that i was
learning
so doing the djing doing performances in
front of a a club a club pa or even
before that when i was doing my djing
stuff as an mc
when the the vinyl skipping and the
crowd are looking at you like yo what
and you've got to improvise quickly so
man's going into some kind of emcee like
you know something amazing
if someone hold the mic i hope they're
trying to find another of vinyl to put
on because this one's going to keep
skipping my hope let's hope there's one
right but like this jump around in my
adidas crate and everyone says whoa and
then i get it to mix somehow perfectly
yeah
and i'm sweating it because i'm thinking
i nearly mashed the whole thing up and
after people come up saying craig i was
sick when you did that thing how did you
do that why are you sweating so much
it's not even hot and it could just
blast and i was like if only you knew
but it teed me up for performances going
forward so when we got to film in
i can just remember something happening
when i was doing
there was a club called sound i think it
was on leicester square
and at this time now rewind have been
released it gone to number two
people didn't really know who i was they
knew the name
which was you know i mean you can get
that was always the using the name was
always like a it's like a tag the dj tag
thing like you you put your name dj
khaled would do it it'd be like i'd be
like craig david
so you knew who was on the record just
in case you you're confused yeah and
then
that then became
sort of my intrinsic trademark thing
that i did throughout that one to do
album um so just be like craig david
it's another one like all that all that
kind of stuff um
but yeah i remember doing this a
performance i had an interview in
capital fm
and i had to get across leicester square
to go and do this
performance of it and sound which
capital were doing like radio
performances from there
i knew something had really changed when
the security there was a security guard
and he had to put me up i went there
with them just being calm i went into
the capital did the interview the
security guard had to put me up on his
shoulders to get me across leicester
square to sound because there were fans
going
crazy like
real i could for for a moment in that
period of time the the justin bieber
thing the
even before the drakes i mean it's like
it was that fever
pitch where it was just like
whoa bts flexor it was like madness like
pandemonium i just like whoa ripping
pulling like it was whoa i was thinking
something's changed
and i went and did the performance and
then filming was was was building up to
be my first number one
and it was my first solo single that
went to number one and it was it was a
song that was released the same
day as as destiny's child saying my name
so to have a number one in the charts
with a group that i've grown up with
posters on my wall and like thinking
this is crazy saying simone is one of my
favorite
r b songs all time
so just for fill me in to do what it did
i knew something had changed i just knew
well it was quite obvious
and i was
on this wave it was euphoric there was
nothing i can i can put my finger on it
was like it was it was everything but
more it went from
everything i touched was turned into
gold because
i everyone wanted a piece of me and i
was doing acoustic performances which
was to give a different feel for
fulfillment which i think was a really
clever
move from
at the time my record label um
was was half owned uh by my now manager
uh colin lester uh telstar and capital
were involved and it was just like we
want to find ways that just didn't
exclude me from other radio stations and
made it feel like it wasn't just this
this radio thing
so we did performances like on ray on uh
tf5 fridays and on uh jules holland
which were acoustic and all of a sudden
i went from the rise and garage
quote start
wow it's actually a song here he's
writing songs
and then the next songs i think kind of
reinforced that it wasn't just just
garage and then from seven days and then
to get to walking away because walking
away it gone clear at that point
really had gone clear like we were
i was in france nearly every other week
in paris doing uh
radio interviews and i'd been in doing a
whole of scandinavia then i'd be in
germany then we'd be getting a flight
over to america and it just started the
whole how old were you through this
period so you start i mean fill me in
was when you were 18. yeah so yeah so
within the album drop the same year so
2001 was when i went over to the states
so it would have been like 19 like how
does how does an 18 19 year old deal
with that because
you know with all the attention comes a
lot of negative stuff it's like
unavoidable it comes with the territory
even with the like the fame and people
clambering on you and stuff
it changes your psychology takes
a shift or you find out who you really
are right they say that a lot like you
find out your demons right because now
you've got the money you've got the
power you've got this admiration so talk
to me about like the
the other side of that
that
meteoric rise
i'd say channeling in of how i or
chewing into how i was at that time
i say the it was euphoric there was that
i was like wow everything's new you're
doing
new places and
going to the best restaurants and your
eyes are wide open you want to play into
this country and
i went i was at the house of blues in in
america doing we had three nights there
and the first night
and i i tell this because it kind of
just to give
context to how bizarre it was so
remember i've come from your flash i
think that girl actually over there let
me do a little mix view over here get a
little half an hour in a set
jump fast forward a few years later
house of blues three nights in a row
first night
missy elliott is has come to to watch
the show i'm looking up thinking
this is crazy like
i can't stand the rain and i don't just
miss the yellow it's the hot next night
i'm there i look up in the same balcony
jennifer lopez is there
i'm like wow
and i want to sound like i'm name
dropping but i want it to be to give
context but yeah it's just these these
facts yeah
the
the the following night
sorry how am i missing this it was it
was missy and beyonce [ __ ] off then it
was jennifer lopez
then on
the last night i look out into the crowd
and there's a lot of kind of attention
on one in particular gentleman that's in
the crowd who's singing i couldn't quite
work out cause the lights were too too
dark so i got the
front house to turn the lights up and i
look in the crowd and i'm singing
walking away and i look over and i see
stevie wonder you see you're looking
walking away and i'm just like
i mean what do you say at that point i
didn't know i felt emotional i felt
because it was stevie wonder from the
record collection from my mom's stuff
beyonce i've got destiny's child on my
wall had jennifer lopez on my wall missy
ellie i don't even listening to before i
come out
it was just like
you can't make this up it was almost
like
yes you view behind the scenes and bam
here it is and then i got to meet him
at the end and he'd come with quincy
jones who we all know is the producer of
all the huge hits for michael jackson
and then quincy said
you know like
nj
you know what he said he said it even
more like like coded he's like yeah
um it's like m he said it's like m's got
your album like it's just like vibe and
i said m
yeah you know mj and michael michael's
got like he's got the army loves born to
do he's been listening to gave it to his
friends i was like let's stop this
if we can if this is this is the thing
we've arrived we're good i've got my fix
there's not much more i could ask for
but it was literally the start of
an incredible rollercoaster ride which
left the later years i think which we
get into it hops back to that and i can
i can see
where the cracks are starting because
when to answer your question about the
other side of it it was so euphoric and
i was so swept up on it it was like
getting on a surfboard and actually
being on the wave and you you're doing i
don't know i never use this word but
like the most gnarliest like you're the
gnarly waves gnarly you know me you're
the
a rip rip curl that's going crazy you're
through the middle of the eye of it
you're on it you're not coming off
but then there was a point
when
the next album slicker than your average
dropped which was only like
a year or so later 2002.
had great success with watch your flavor
and and songs were hitting but there was
this
born to do it had now done seven million
albums
six times platinum oh six times platinum
it's still still crazy and when you said
about the wembley arena three times sold
out i'm standing outside the sign i got
in my mom's house like there's a picture
of i'm like
you just can't make it up it's it was so
beautiful and i'm so grateful for those
times
but i started to see from the slick in
your average time where
the record label would already start to
quota i was going to do 10 11 million
obviously slicker than your average
because now the trajectory is going to
be has to go higher than this
so then when the album ended up coming
out
they ended up
selling 3.5 million albums
and 3.5
million albums
yet at the time i remember
that there was this feeling in the
company of ah
hmm right only 3.5 and i'm i'm i'm
impressionable i'm a young kid i don't
know i've just got into this the music
business and you're telling me that
that's not a good thing because the last
time i checked the feeling i'm getting
is i just saw 3.5 million albums give
3.5 million to any artist now
like we were good
so i'd already started to buy into
there was some it was there was a
trajectory was starting to go in a
different place that that
i wouldn't even know about figures i
didn't really care about albums cells i
was just like i'm just happy to be here
and i'm making music and i'm doing what
i love my dream
but that was the first learning curve of
the the defining of defining of product
and defining of
you being a commodity that has to
achieve something now that you've set it
up here whereas i thought it got fun
when you started to do i thought it got
more playful no no they got more serious
and there's more cooks in the kitchen
and everyone's got an opinion of the
song you should be releasing
beyond expectation the curse of all
happiness and joy and you must know this
you're just trying to equate what you're
self worth through so many other
people's
expectation of you like you said so i'm
trying to say okay cool well
we're here i'm a songwriter i'd always
i'd always had a really great rapport
with my manager colin esther who's been
with me like for i've got i love the
conversations that we we've had over the
years and
and him even saying early doors
that i can't guarantee you success
i but i'll do everything in my power to
to to protect you and keep you safe so
you can do your thing and having those
kind of confidence in in in the people
that you're working with is is paramount
when you do start to get these the
feedback trickling through because i
never was like oh yeah what are today's
midweeks i wasn't really too interested
in like finding out all the stats
because what happens is and you can get
this now and i say this to any aspiring
artist
who's putting music out now and you're
having success
is literally just enjoy it fully be
immersed in it because if you start to
check for what's going on next week
your moment when you're supposed to have
the number one and you're enjoying life
you're already gonna be able to see by
tuesday wednesday that your numbers
already showing that you're already
number three now you slipped off and
they're number one so your moment of
glory was actually there was the curve
and at the point where you got the thing
which is the beautiful metal
number one
or you really know you're already kind
of on the decline so
it's that i had to
ride that for a few more albums if i'm
being honest to i was making songs and
they were connecting but if it was a
number four
in the charts it wasn't number one like
it was before i haven't got the same
amount of time that i had to make those
songs i've got haven't got enough
life really
all this sort of those first albums
there is seminal because it's all your
life up until that point right
and then after that the expectation is
we need it on a deadline and we need it
this time and you've got hit this in the
midst of the fact you're doing a hundred
interviews and you're doing you're
flying all over the place but still
you've got to conjure up that thing
i don't know any artists that that won't
feel that and
hats often kudos to anyone who is able
to sustain that but as a human being
i know that's a tour order for anyone to
be able to
to continuously do and you start to see
with any of the artists who
we put in
from from the amy winehouses to the
michael jacksons to the whitney houstons
the height of success when it is like
whoa like otherworldly
there's so much
of the the human part that's being unmet
that it gets to the point where breaking
point and then something happens because
it's drug addiction or if it moves into
mental health issues and depression
which are all
so real that no human can vibrate at
that level for that amount of time and i
i'm thankful for those moments that kind
of shaved off a little bit of the it
being all go go because i think that it
kind of made me have to go back to a lot
of things that were
like when my grandmother passed away
which on the next down story goes
i was back in my heart again it's like
i'm writing a song like johnny about
bullying or i'm talking about let her go
a song i wrote from about my grandmother
to my mum to say that i know it's
crushing you you lost your mom and i've
lost my grandma who's pretty much raised
me
here's a song and i want you to hear it
and those things that start to get back
in my heart because we can get heady and
when it starts to get heady you're out
of you're not in sync with this this is
the real brains and i've learned that
now it's not this is a is a loyal
servant to the heart but if you go from
here and then that
you can find the
ways to get to
a to b but it has to start from here you
know
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as we all know
energy independence and living a little
greener has never been more important
for a better future it's a journey i've
been on over the last couple of years
that i've shared with you sporadically
ever since i sold my range over sport
and bought an electric bicycle and
there's a lot of people out there that
listen to this podcast that are looking
to make that sustainable switch in the
things that run their daily life whether
it's their home their car their vehicles
whatever it might be so when a good
friend of mine at a company called my
energy called jordan told me she was
interested in sponsoring this podcast i
jumped at the opportunity so for those
of you that don't know my energy are a
uk renewable energy brand whose mission
is to increase the usage of green energy
helping people like you and i to save
time and money when it comes to making
sustainable switches in our lives so if
this resonates with you and you're the
type of person that's been looking or
thinking about going on your own
sustainability journey i highly
recommend checking them out at
myenergy.com
and you describe that journey as a as a
roller coaster so what at what point did
that roller coaster start heading down
from that um place you described as
euphoria to a place where you
um weren't euphoric
talk talk to me about the down part of
the roller coaster i'd say
when i released
the trust me album in 2009 um
it just felt there was
from where i'd started off with
very cultural records like rewind and
fill me in which is why we talked
earlier how their songs even played now
and they still seem to hit
when i when i look at
2009 and the trust me album
i
i felt like i was starting to
make music that was to please please
people and to tick boxes it was like i
was there's a song called top of the
hill which is a lovely song
i love the song but if you listen to
that song to how it started off it was
very far removed the type of music was
becoming very live and it wasn't as
it wasn't as synth-based and then so
which i'd drawn all my inspirations from
as a kid and that's not to say that you
can't experiment but i knew at that
point i was entering into a new space
and then by the time i released that
album which i was proud of i'm always
proud of the music i put out but
it wasn't connecting as well
science hill delivered was
an album that i did
just after that which was i was out of a
deal at the time
um just because i'd run the tenure of my
my deal
so it was kind of a fresh start i could
look at different record labels
universal were excited so we did a deal
with universal then i was put out this
album called science hill delivered
which was a covers album
and i was singing like
doc of the bay
and the title song science delivered
from stevie
but verbatim like the originals it
wasn't some chopped and screwed it
wasn't an r b version it wasn't a garage
thing it wasn't like your it was like
the same song the same song
and i felt like it was time that i
needed to sort of check myself and just
be like
are you getting the fun out of this like
you used to
do you want to continue making music
like this
and thankfully the the the the world
always the universe always mirrors
everything that you're going through so
it mirrors your state of play of where
you are so i always felt that
i was if the feeling i was getting was
being mirrored back i'm not quite
feeling this
so the world says cool i'll give you
more of you're not quite feeling this in
your circumstances that happen around
you whereas when i was the kid growing
up making the first album i was feeling
everything i was feeling the song on the
way home from the studio i was feeling
it on my sub speaker at home i was
feeling those rides up in the car to do
the performance it was feeling
and now i check in with that deeply
because i know that anytime i'm not
feeling it
act from that not from the head saying
well i know seo had a big covers album
at the time i think that was a good
reference point he had a huge covers
albums doing
serious numbers and that was the
sentiment that universal were presenting
like do a covers record
no brainer you can sing these songs
motown gonna be good it's a soul thing
and then i'll springboard off the back
of that with your own
album that was the the play
was never really worked out that way
because it didn't really work out as an
album it didn't hit the way it did and
there was no
next album that came from off the back
of that there was a period of time where
i was like i was at the scene for a
second and what did you do then this is
when you moved to miami
yeah so i was in i was in miami from
2010 so it was like about a year after
that album and i was there for about
five six years for the first two three
years the best time probably of my life
being out there
anything and everything that you could
possibly think of miami being and what
it was representing
but the latter period of that period
that time
was where something was ringing inside
of me of
you're in the wrong place
and this is what intuition is very quiet
and it and it's it's it's really creeps
up and it's it's a night it's like not
even nagging it's like you hear it and
you just i don't want to hear it i want
to
it's all this it looks great over here
you know i mean it looks so
aesthetically pleasing for me i mean the
car and the department and the parties
and the women and just it was like the
parties that were just like
every day of the week something going on
music isn't really getting recorded now
because the voice is is just
destroyed from like shouting in a club
and
doing a nonsense
so muse is getting pushed to the side
all those fancy toys and the vibes
starting to become more important it
means like that
my balance of of actual supply and
demand of music that got me there was
way off i was literally creating hardly
anything is there shades of like you
you're going up on this trajectory when
you're like a younger man 18 19 etc and
then going into this place where you
almost abandoned your like your essence
and your roots and then you that kind of
culminates and you're making this covers
album which is almost
it's quite it's almost a bit of a
metaphor because then you were really
being someone else like doing cover
albums is by definition you're covering
other people's music on their own style
and then almost this um
this period in miami where you get into
partying is it seems like a bit of a
distraction maybe or whatever trying to
explore trying to get some other
pleasure from another type of life yeah
and then kind of going back to your your
roots in a way where you all of that you
tasted the [ __ ] yes you'd had the don
perrion you know and you and that wasn't
it so now you go back and ask yourself
what is it what is it and then it seems
like with ts5 you you created
a new kind of expression of who craig
david is and who he always was
maybe who you lost sight of over the
years because of all these temptations
and your own success
ain't that the truth when you start to
realize that actually going back
to the things that
and it's all back in childhood this is
the thing when i tune in it's like the
decks and the dj and the mixtapes that
was all i was trying to do when i was
doing the ts5 house party i just wanted
to feel that again like i'm mixing now
with my little pioneer dj setup and i'm
on the microphone being the host of the
most this and
i want everyone to feel that feeling
that i got into the whole thing for and
if someone doesn't know what ts5 is yeah
can you explain just give an overview of
exactly what it is yeah so ts5 is like
um
it's
when i the performance now from the
house party that it was
um
is i'm able to
close the dj when i first started off as
we've spoken about before and i was at
that point then dj fade so i honed all
my skills on on using vinyl and technics
1210s the ts5 set is the name came from
the
apartment
in miami and it's a show where i'm able
to dj and mix other people's records as
much as drop my ones in
and they will come to come out of my my
dj booth and sing and do a performance
in a way for me that is it is giving me
all the feels i got from when i was a dj
but also i can do the performances and
drop
some gems in there at the same time like
i can play a tlc no scrubs or i can play
saying my name and then go into filming
i just love it and
taking that to pool parties i did now
betha i think i was trying to set the
tone of like this isn't a dj set where i
can get away with
playing some songs doing a few shots of
tequila with my mates and get paid for
it and go home i just can't like i get
that can work in certain
and i have no judgment it's do your
thing but for me as a performer
mixing the tunes is like it's so easy
now like with vinyl was like that was a
mission but like now so i can mix the
tunes that's nothing but to come out of
the booth perform do an mc thing and hit
the marker back inside to get to the
next song
that's for me i i pride myself on it's
giving me a whole new lease of life for
festivals so that's really what ts5 is
and it's become a phenomenal brand
phenomenal brand for for music putting
and it's it's funny because it's such an
it's it's quite rare that you have
someone that has that kind of skill
stack
of all those different pieces that can
do that i think that's probably why it's
been such a such a hit is because you
rarely see someone who can drop their
own records who can sing who can perform
but then who can also dj it's like a
really interesting new thing totally
yeah i i felt i felt it and i got a
little touch of it in the party when i
was in in my house prize
i mean i didn't even start to put see
this is
it's beautiful when you look back at the
puzzle pieces when the picture starts to
become a little bit more clearer as you
put okay that puzzle that piece there
meant you needed that piece to happen
for this one to happen
so when i was performing in my house i
wasn't actually performing in my own
songs at all because i just felt like i
don't want to start dropping my own
songs in the middle of the thing
and then i have people come over and be
like
drop that film me in drop rewind
one girl came over said
drop seven days and i was like nah she
goes please is my favorite song and i
was like and i literally was like maybe
i might do a verse just one one
and it started
me the idea of putting a couple of my
songs in and then we started to record
the set i'll start to record the set and
put on soundcloud so people could listen
to it after because people were like oh
where can i get i'd love to listen to it
back to that set or we did sang a happy
birthday to someone and it was a moment
that they wanted to hear again no one
caught it and i was like well let me
capture this now
and that was actually
where it flipped back into mixtape land
that i then got my manager took it into
kiss kiss originally were like we can
air this put it out as a show and then
it went on to capital capital aired it
as well and capital extra so all of a
sudden it was like it's gone from a
house party to a thing and then we did a
couple of early shows one uh two shows
in hackney
to see if this house party would
translate into an actual thing and when
i saw people it going off in the same
way i thought wow this isn't just a
miami thing you know it's not just in my
house it's actually people connecting
with it and since then i guess
glastonbury was probably the
one of the pinnacle of it because you're
there in front of a crowd who are there
for a murray at a different artist
and you're there performing a band set
and then go into a dj set and to see it
going off i was like this is my people
from miami who were early doors
when we first did that party which was
like nine of us just messing about
having a couple shots with playing off
itunes it's a glaston route to
glastonbury that was that was crazy so
it just
it's always there the pieces are always
there but time
sometimes you just need to have time and
patience in this it's so interesting
looking at your story as like an
outsider and watching that journey of
you being this like huge mega star then
the the downside of the roller coaster
as you describe it and then watching you
over the last like five six seven
eight years
come back out with as almost like this
completely new character but with a
proposition that's as
resonant as what you used to do a very
very different proposition but you like
okay from my like not really paying
attention to what's going on in the
world because i'm not really that into
pop culture
you know i used to listen to my walkman
and then there was a gap and then you're
back in again where everyone's talking
about craig david again but for a
completely different proposition but it
appears to be a completely different
proposition
that's not common or easy the question i
actually have for you is because it's a
roller coaster your mind goes on the
roller coaster as well and this kind of
brings me into the topic of mental
health yeah
be honest with me what was the mental
health journey throughout that whole
period of time
do you
know where i sit in
there was a long period of time
i
i guess that those um
those words of
of of man are poor
or
you just just just just just just roll
with it just roll with it just man
is the most amount of nonsense
that i've ever had because it's that in
of itself is what it's what's caused
the crazy suicide rates that we see
especially in men and the way in which
it's spiraling out of control because
it's like keep it inside repress it put
it under the carpet don't talk about it
that's what we do that very alpha
way and thankfully
and this goes back to my parents my
grandma and my my mom in particular
it was all about open conversation and
then and speaking and have have open
conversation and be able to get it out
and have a convo
and i think that there was periods where
i just
i rode through it and i think miami was
kind of just
was it was a break from a lot of things
and me being out there and being a
different climate a different
culture
enjoying
those things but that still wasn't
fulfilling what i was really looking for
what i really wanted was connection and
relationship in a way that i'd
experienced
almost in those kind of early doors
before the first album and at the when
it hit so
the roller coaster ride is
you find character in your lows 100 you
you ask the questions the real question
do you really want to do this are you
really about this and i am a musician
through and through
um and i love it but the
the
depression is real
mental health in the in the
multitude of myriad of different ways
that that can come about is real and
it's that and it's something that
you can only half the battle i've always
spoken about that you is talking to it's
being able to express that to someone
you can confide in and even if it's not
something you can provide it in a phone
line that you can pick up and just speak
to someone you don't know maybe in some
ways that can be even better you can
just go i've got my chest and they're
giving you they're hearing you they see
you
but that's only half the battle the rest
is then a journey of they call it in
more spiritual circles dark knight the
soul of going through into a place where
you're going to uncover everything that
was put under that carpet
having to bring it to the light and
having to bring it up and work through
it to find
a place where you pull the carpet up and
all the dust goes up everywhere and then
you start to see where it lands you
start saying okay this was a story that
i was telling myself the things i was
defining myself of myself self-worth
through how i looked and the approval of
others
this is authority figures feeling like
they had something
over me the power i had when i was the
entrepreneur selling chocolates and and
making the songs that's really you who
i've always been but i had
abandoned you used that earlier
abandoning yourself when that starts to
happen
it could spiral out of control and i had
injuries and and physical injuries
through all the training and stuff that
i did as well
that spiraled me into different
depths of depression where i was just
like whoa i've never experienced this
when things happen that you've never
they cumulatively build up
but then
there's something that breaks it just
snaps it and at that point it just feels
like whoa and you're trying to
you're free fall that's the feeling i
feel with depression i've experienced
that i know how it is and i haven't
really been as vocal i guess as
today about like that and i feel it's
necessary because it's
i don't want to be that one who's
telling a story i want to be so
authentic and i want to open up like you
said you spoke about things that
you needed to get off your chest and let
people know the other side of all this
because in that
is where all the beauty and empathy
really is and people can connect and
they say oh what so you went through
that
ah
so it isn't this thing that only me and
all of a sudden we're all connected and
i'm thinking yes and then i'm i'm
inspired by people who kind of wear the
heart on their sleeves now
so
yeah
i feel like it was a culmination of a
lot of those things building up to being
in the wrong place being away from my
family missing being able to just make
music in the way i did coming back to
the uk and then
as soon as i did that and i felt i felt
my first huge hug when i walked in and
saw big nasty
corrupted fm uh mr jam uh storms using
the building shola amma and i did
this this one extra performance which
was really i was going to rock up and
vibe fill me in
and i ended up singing it over where are
you now that the justin bieber diplo
skrillex instrumental
there was this moment of love i felt big
nasty gave me a hug first when i came in
wearing his heart and sleep booty man's
my tune oh my god great booty man is my
song and i'm like whoa like really
wearing his heart sleeve
and then sing this song i sing fill me
in as a remix vibe over this
instrumental and it went so viral
that i'm looking on my phone i'm seeing
justin bieber like saying like whoa
that's amazing that you need to check it
45 minutes into the show then i'm seeing
skrillex on my timeline i'm seeing diplo
on the timeline i'm just thinking
something's happened here
but it was
more than just
it needed me to play my part and get
back home and get and go through that
miami phase of what that was all about
i i i find that really interesting that
that's the fit so
is was that that miami phase the first
phase in your life where you encountered
what you believed to be like depressive
symptoms where you felt fell into a
depression in the in the latter stages
of mommy yeah because i got injured out
there my back went like in like in my
lower back
and i never felt a pain like that in my
life like i felt aches and pains of of
training incidents and different things
i've had like anyone who's had like a
blowout in the back
but this one in particular was just like
it was a feeling that just wouldn't give
up so i was my movement patterns was
went from you know you're 100 you're
doing the last kind of leg leg press and
now
it's all these it's dead lifts and i've
got respect for deadlift amazing move
but when your if your back goes on one
of those
i promise you will
there's a feeling that you have which is
like putting your hands in like 240
volts in the wall that it's just it's
different it's like it's a nerve pain
which is not like an ache or like all
feels a bit sore like you've got doms
from doing too many kind of like some
glute work
so when it went
i was like
i've never felt anything quite like this
and it made me
have to check myself in a whole
different way for the fact that every
movement i did felt like i was getting
that same spasm so it wasn't just like
one spasm it wasn't like okay we've
locked up we're good
at that point you know where you're at
i've had those before we all had i think
in our lives we have a sporadic moment
we have a thing
this was now it's happening now it's
happening now it's happening now like it
was continuous nerve
spasm i was like
it was a spiral for me it was it was a
point where i had dark thoughts i was
just like i can't live my life like this
so i understood
really at that point the first time
depression hit me and i couldn't reframe
it as being positive i couldn't say this
is put a positive spin on it there was
nothing so i'd had the mental thing
so i was getting i kind of signed up for
for a good uh
for to to be someone who you have to
experience certain things to be able to
speak on it and i get that now so it's
like okay we've you come here to to to
on mission to do this
you're gonna have to feel pain
physically you're gonna have to feel
heartbreak you're gonna have to feel
anxiety and abandonment of of your body
you're gonna have to feel all these
things
and then i hope that you get to a point
where you get the memo which i've now
fully understood the memo i don't need
to be doing deadlifts and i don't need
to be training like the way i trained
before i can stay healthy and more
importantly what people enjoyed from me
was music that it never had changed and
i realized that from when i came back to
london
it was like people just want to hear
music and they were cool they were just
happy and this version of me and i love
all the other versions because it all
played a part this isn't a judgment
thing like oh yeah well
we always tend to be like yeah an album
comes out you're like yeah it's no good
anymore this is the one night
they all played a part to me sitting
here today with you and being able to
break down things and unpack things and
as a
as a as a man now to be open enough to
say i know what depression feels like i
speak differently on things now and the
more i can open up and speak on
the pain that i felt and that back thing
ran for years it was like a couple years
two three years i was like
and even i mean today i'll put my hands
up i'm still working out like jeremy we
do we do surgery do we not do we like
i'm it's it's dialed down incredibly but
it was a defining moment it's pivotal to
me and it just was like whoa
and like i said
depression
you'll have dark thoughts dark thoughts
you'll have you start having thoughts so
you're like if this pain can
continuously goes on like this
then
i i can't
it sounds crazy for me to say because
that gives me the nicest guy and you're
so positive and you're like how could it
but i was like i just can't live like i
can't live like this so you start
not thinking about ways that you would
say
um lose um take your life or to to dip
out but if you start having thoughts of
something has to happen like this this
pain is intolerable i can't even style
it out there's nothing for it and i
think that that
when it started to dial down and we've
done it from injections and all
different kinds of things conservatively
and strengthening the the
multifidus and the paraspinals and the
glutes i know my body so well now it got
me back into my body
more importantly i start to understand
the mechanics of how my body works
whenever we listen to things you know we
get a little ache in a pain or you get a
little thing telltale sign that's 10
years ago you've got a blow out and then
it blows out again and you didn't listen
you keep going all that does it just
amps up the sound till you get the one
you got the memo now okay cool now
you've got the mem that's how the
universe works so i'm really intriguing
my body when it starts telling me stuff
i'm like
i need to check for this early because i
don't want that five-year thing and the
thing's going to let me know the hard
way
it's dialed down
thank god but all part of the plan
because it's put me in a place where i
can physically go out there and do my
shows like i love i can go out there and
perform like i love i don't need to be
putting the extra work in in a gym to
satisfy anything that's i can go
swimming i can move my body and i and i
can
the things i can dial it up and we can
get whatever would you we'll be looking
for but who is it for it's not for
anyone anymore i don't need that but you
are
back you're back in the uk now back at
the uk back in the uk
um and you said this you said this quote
you said to a lot of people i'm at my
destination i've arrived i'm back
but no i'm still on my journey
and i'm not taking my foot off the gas
now that that phrase foot on the gas
right
it kind of sounds it has hints of a
former craig
yeah when you even set foot off the gas
here
i don't know what day i was saying that
or what i was going to do
yeah
when you said it to me then i knew
exactly as you were gonna say like
what's this one on the gas thing because
that would suggest that your
head strong run into it yeah yeah yeah i
i i get the sentiment but then also the
phrase the terminology is a little bit
it's this is troubling right yeah yeah
it's like we're not didn't take the foot
off the gas just relax
for the save your petrol just just calm
yourself stay sometimes staying still
weirdly enough is actually the one i
recognize when i stay still and the
world moves
it's like wow pandemic
yeah that i've got to say had for for
everything and
the pain it caused and the people who
lost their lives and families that were
that were
suffering so deeply and still are um
when you look at just how it was a pause
on the whole world and it just had
people
recognizing that one they had to
relinquish control because they got to a
point well i can't control this so
okay break open the monopoly board let's
let's let's have a game then
all of a sudden
back into kid back into the child again
the child was seen play started to
happen
and as much as like we we we all like to
say that we need to be the thing of
doing doing doing but sometimes doing
nothing
don't don't don't think that the world
isn't working for you behind the scenes
here when you're doing nothing like
having a good night's sleep resting
trust me for the working out in the gym
and all those kind of things the rest
was the actual thing whereas growth
happened
so why would that be no different for
the way that we are when let me let me
sleep on this
let me slow down and
man it's it's a blessing to see someone
as inspired and conscious as you putting
it out there and allowing people like
myself to come through speak our truth
have people have a platform to speak and
feel open and not feel like they're
boxed in having to kind of got the media
training here have to be there open out
because that's what we need we've done
that the old patriarchal system is
crashing down yeah it's not working
anymore no one wants to
divide and conquer and fight it ain't
gonna work we want love we want a
heart-based relationship so that failed
us right we tried that and it failed
failed to felt deeply man yeah just
really did and as we look forward you've
got this album coming out which i'm
really excited about called 22
and it's coming out on the 24th of june
this year yeah talk to me you know
throughout this it's been 22 years as
well since you your first
first album yeah
so 22 years later
your album 22 comes out what can i
expect from this what what is the
inspiration what is the the art the
creativity the pain what is the what is
what is it okay so
we know born to do it was
was my baby it broke out everything for
me it was the moment where everything i
built up into that point
it was me getting the
the golden ticket let's say it's the
golden ticket we're entering into the
the chocolate factory now excited
but not the ending right then i had to
go through life a little and now i'm
landing at this place in my life where
and during the pandemic gave me a lot of
time to write a lot of songs about
studio at home so i just i was writing a
lot of songs and i had no rush it felt
like how i was when i made my first
album if i wanted to do a verse today
call if not i'm going to go downstairs
to the kitchen and maybe i'll throw on a
movie and maybe i'll come back up
i was grateful that i had that the
privilege to be able to do that and to
make home uh
as productive as if i wanted it to be or
as relaxed as i wanted to be
it feels like it has all the it has all
the feels
it feels like has all the feels of
my first album want to do it i feel like
the kid again and i keep using the word
feel because i think that's the most
important that's my that's the only
thing i can really gauge thing how am i
feeling i've got a big sub speaker in my
in my new in my in my home in in in
london again same thing literally i got
to i literally just patted the same
thing with a couple of blue lights to
make you just look a little bit like oh
it's a 2.0 version of the same but same
big speaker i can play it loud i've had
people come over and i've said you you
need to understand what bases like
really because they think they know what
basically or the sonar system and it's
all cool got a little couple subs
listen to this and you get that
it's different
so i feel like i've got the rmb on there
i've got the the garage on there i've
got songs that i feel that weave a
beautiful
journey of where i'm at now i feel i'm
speaking on things that
it's coming from a place where i can
still have the lingo and the languaging
that doesn't set you off as being like
oh you were like in the 2000s and you're
well no one says that anymore no one's
saying tipsy in the in the club anymore
no one's even really saying getting wavy
anymore that's sort of like a bit a
couple years back johnny's what's the
news so
working with young
artists working with young fresh
songwriters they'll give me languaging
that allows me to get my messaging
across but in a way that it can get the
most broadest kind of reach
i just feel like we've
yeah i don't want to guess it because it
feels like every artist does that right
yeah it's just
it feels really true to where i'm at
right now and i've got i listen to it
and i'm excited to listen back to
this album and as i have done since
really the following tuition album since
i came back 2016 did that one time is
now and this one but this one feels like
with that i'm a journeyman that's the
the cover album cover is me on a journey
and i feel like that journeyman of just
22 years in now and as i said to the
willy wonka element i feel like charlie
who's now going through the test
he got a little caught up which if you
clock it it was his grandpa who kind of
got him to take that fizzy uh fizzy um
lifting drink and he started to go up
into the thing it wasn't really charlie
he was calm he was actually being the
good one across it was his granddad that
kind of going right
to get to the end
where the everlasting gobstopper part
where he has a choice to sell himself
out go sell it for 50 000 pounds i think
to the the competitor chocolate maker of
slugworth or does he go back and put it
back on willy wonka's desk and do the
right thing knowing he's going away with
nothing
i feel like i'm at that place where i'm
in
i've created an album
and i'm willing to
i'm willing to trade in all of the
things that i'd up into this point this
pretence that maybe i had behind the
scene that people didn't win i i've
there's always getting 80 of me but
there was a 20 and that's enough or 10
of me that's not it's enough it's like
the uh the princess and the p trust me
it's underneath there and it will keep
getting you it's like the thorn in the
foot it's like it doesn't have to be big
it's not some big drama but it's
getting you right
i want to pull the thorn out i want to
find the p all right i want to i want to
say i want to sleep on my knight in my
mattress where i'm not feeling slightly
uncomfortable because i know there's
something underneath there's there's a
needle in the haystack and i don't want
i know it's in there yeah we gotta find
it i'm at that stage where i'm dropping
this album that i feel i've put the
blasting gobstopper back and i have no
idea if willy wonka's gonna turn around
and say
charlie you did it i knew you would do
it i had to test you i had to test you
he's like what what the chocolate no
more than the chocolate what is it got
the whole chocolate factory you've got
the whole chocolate magic and his family
can move in and everyone can be part of
it and that's how i'm feeling now
everyone can be part of this this is
this is different now so i'm excited man
oh i'm excited and you know i'm i was
excited before but hearing your
description of it and feeling your
energy about where this is coming from
and it's coming from that place of like
your intuition your wisdom and your
maturity and over those 22 years all of
that
unbelievable twisting journey that
you've been on to create a record now um
[Music]
which inc like which sort of collects
all of that wisdom
and all of that emotion and truth and
pain and experience is really something
to be um
excited about as a as a craig david fan
so thank you for for giving us another
project i i've not heard it yet they
wouldn't they wouldn't let me hear it
but i but i can't i can't wait
because i always feel like these these
moments have always more than
you've done
you you've done your your moment
together but i just feel there's a
friendship building here anyway
i'll play the album we'll get some food
and we'll vibe so it's calm you'll be
well ahead of the game no do you know
from the minute you walked in the door i
felt like i'd known you a long time and
that's a credit to you because i meet a
lot of people here right so sometimes
people come in and maybe they're a
little bit colder and like that you know
there's a lot of things going on in
their lives which i'm unaware of so i've
got to have empathy for that but the
minute you walked in through the door it
was like you were my brother and it's
like we're known each other
that's that's a honestly it's a credit
to you so
thank you thank you so much for your
time we have a closing tradition on this
podcast
which is the previous guest writes and
the next guest a question nice so okay
and i don't get to see what it is until
open the book nice nice so the preview
and this is a very good one in fact very
fitting the previous guest wrote if you
could whisper in the ear of your 14 year
old self what would you whisper
that's good that's good that's good
listen craig
my nose might freak you out because
you're hearing a voice in your ear right
now but
trust me i'm i'm a little older version
of you and
everything you're about to do right now
is going to change your life in the most
beautiful way and i want you just to
enjoy every moment and know that there
will be times that will be quite hard
but know that i'm here
know that i'm always there holding your
hand along the way and i promise you
that once you get through them
the feeling you will have will be like
the euphoria you are just about to
experience in a couple years time so get
ready and trust me
the crowd are gonna go off when they
hear something soon okay
love to you my man
amen
it was like a prayer
thank you so much okay
honestly it's a huge honor and your
vulnerability and openness you don't
know you won't ever get to see the
impact it has i probably will i'll get
the comments and the messages and you
will as well but the impact of you being
being
self-aware enough and man enough to be
vulnerable i think is is really
something which i i applaud you for
because you just don't really you know
the impact you're going to have on a lot
of young men specifically
is is profound and uh yeah long-lasting
so thank you thank you and fearless
mutual man very genuine i appreciate
thank you
[Music]
you